[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony
michaels hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
i don't know if you've heard
but the kid diddlers
in tennessee
[Music]
apparently we put him on blast yesterday
around the entire world
and they were like oh that's that's
really bad imagery that's a horrible
imagery we gotta backtrack we're gonna
make sure that we put the age 18 in that
bill
not not no age limit
seems real convenient yesterday we
blasted all over the airwaves
they
they tuck tail and run on their age
limit of course they do why wouldn't
they
they've been discovered as kid diddlers
the republican the republican party
we're not going to forget this
this is not like
especially here at this [ __ ] show
this is not like we're just going to go
oh well maybe it was a clerical error no
it was not a clerical error
they're going to continue
this scourge
for your children
they've shown their cards folks they've
shown us who they are they're out in the
open
the republican kid dealers will not stop
you think just because they changed no
oh oh oh my god
they they discovered they discovered
that we're pedophiles we better change
the bill quickly before anyone notices
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we noticed we know who you are
we know who you we know who your enemy
is
fascist
you know i i was thinking a lot
yesterday about this bill especially
after it was amended
and i thought
you know
what if what if
they passed that bill in tennessee
and a 35 40 year old woman were to marry
a ten-year-old boy
i would say they would lock her up
they were like nope this law was never
intended
for an adult woman to marry a little boy
and take away his take away his manhood
we know what the law was intended for
you know you know what it was intended
for
you know exactly
what they were trying to do
their intention was for old men to marry
girls little
girls it's
what it was intended for
to marry
children
i tweeted yesterday
you can't abort babies but you sure as
hell can marry them
republicans everywhere
that's the rub folks
this is their party don't believe me
don't believe me look at the vote
look at the vote
in the house
to investigate war crimes
six republicans six
were like no no no no no no don't
don't investigate war crimes because if
we call if we call what putin's doing
war crimes what we want to do in this
country would be considered war crimes
don't doubt that's where they're at
they're getting really [ __ ] close
they're trying they were gonna try it
listen they were gonna try to pass a law
in tennessee
for a bunch of adult men
to marry little baby girls
got it
and as soon as as soon i mean the minute
we start blasting it all over the
airwaves they're like oh no we we didn't
mean that that's not that's not what
we're not actually uh
pedophile we're not actually pedophiles
we're not uh we're not actually
pedophiles we're just uh
we met we meant uh we meant change the
age to 18. we didn't actually mean we
could marry anyone we want whenever we
want
because we're white old men who have
power
we didn't actually
mean that
just forget we ever
did that bill there
nope not gonna forget not doing that
they own that [ __ ] now hook line sinker
the whole thing
from now until forever
never gonna forget that [ __ ]
that these republicans are
i mean the evidence is clear
they can't stop talking they cannot stop
talking about sexualizing kids gender
they sexualize children's gender over
and over and over in florida candace
owens does a video about it
about how she's gonna
somehow disney is some kind of
sexualizing kids what the [ __ ] is she
talking about
[ __ ] maniac
[ __ ] weirdos
concerned about people's genitalia in
bathrooms
worried about who's marrying who who
loves who sexualizing love
sexualizing kids gender
then they want to marry kids i don't
know maybe that's one reason why they're
totally against abortion is
i mean if you if you if you abort
and have an abortion well that's just
less crop for these old white men
to marry i mean really if you think
about it
how are they going to get a date how are
they going to get married if you abort
all the babies they want to marry them
now
i'm not going to forget this folks this
isn't going to be like oh yeah we won
that fight let's move on i don't think
so
we are going to continue continue to
beat this drum
you want to win the 2022 midterms is
that what you want to do
i know pro-democracy people out there
that are absolutely terrified that these
fascists are going to take over the
house of representatives and the senate
terrified not just that secretary of
state offices attorney generals
governors
they're on our doorstep folks
and they've shown us who they are
especially in texas florida and now
tennessee
so it's time
it's time to roll out the messaging
and play the little game that they like
to play when when we do elections in
politics
it's well past time as far as i'm
concerned
they
they voted
six
house republicans voted
not to investigate the war crimes that
putin is committing in ukraine he is
killing innocent women and children men
civilians
executing them
in ukraine
and six house republicans like man now
you know what let's not investigate
those war crimes you know if if we
investigate those war crimes they might
want to investigate war crimes that we
would like to commit
doubt me
go back in your little history book
do a little bit of research
of how this stuff works
and how the slow trickle of fascism
don't believe me paul goes-r
he's a house rep
he's going to a white nationalist
meeting on hitler's birthday of all of
all
of all of all days he's gonna go
celebrate with a bunch of white
nationalists adolf hitler's birthday
fantastic
member of congress
and they [ __ ] love him
they love him oh they love his kind of
crazy it's just on brand for them
on brand for ron desantis
that bigot
in florida
the transphobe down in texas greg abbott
and now the kid diddlers over in
tennessee so yeah
yeah we're gonna frame this up and we're
gonna keep after them we're not gonna
forget just because they seen that oh a
child brides
that really didn't hit well with the
american public so we're gonna back up
on that
we're just gonna forget the whole we
wanted to marry children thing don't
don't pay attention no we're gonna pay
attention to that republican party
all of you every last one of you
i haven't heard one not not one not one
prominent
federal politician senator
former senator
congress person who stood in front of a
microphone yesterday denouncing the law
in tennessee not one you point them out
to me send me the video send me the
audio
send me the news report i'd love to see
it
not one
so guess what they own it hook line
sinker you don't get to back away from
your pedophilia
from you from old men wanting to marry
young
young girls
not gonna happen not gonna happen we
have a special guest today
co-host from legal af
kfa karen friedman
agnipolo
it is going to be fantastic we have
several subjects i want to talk about
you guys have heard this secret service
bombshell
what in the hell is going on in
washington dc
what is this story
i'm watching all kinds of videos of the
fbi going into an apartment building
called the crossing this morning
this thing is huge but i also
she has a a very special resume and i
want to ask her about the manhattan d.a
because she has a little bit of insight
into what that office is and what it can
and can't be and i want to ask her about
the d.a brag and how the governor
could or could not
have
some influence over that office and
possibly what legal influence the
governor has and what decisions the
governor of new york can make
over that investigation in the manhattan
da's office so we're going to ask her
about that but the main reason why i had
her on is because i really want to
repent because we're coming we're really
getting to the point where we should be
seeing
a lot of movement out of the department
of justice a lot of people are blaming
merrick garland a lot of people are
blaming the january 6th select committee
so i really want to get her insight in
what she thinks about the doj and
merrick garland
and how that is all
that process is working with the january
6th select committee and the january 6
investigation into the insurrection
and the coup attempt the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup attempt
so i want to get her opinion on those
things so stick around everyone's here
this morning everyone's here debbie from
salt lake robin is here uh kathy's here
andrea's here uh minus margie's here
amanda's here for us from facebook is
here let's give some shout outs here uh
corey from facebook christina's here
nancy's here
uh mj good morning mj
uh crystal is here charlene is here
kaelin's here nancy's here
you guys this is fantastic you guys know
we broadcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
live we live stream it's like a radio
show
live radio
now we come to you through through the
books of face on the midas touch
facebook page
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific make sure to go to our youtube
channel and follow our youtube channel
as well just go to thetonymichaels.com
or just search tony michael's podcast on
youtube and you will find it you will
find it but stick around we're gonna
come right back we have our special
guest k
f a
as soon as we return stick around we'll
be right back
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us we have a
special guest we're going to ask about
several topics here we're going to start
asking about the manhattan pa
bragg the brand new d.a
we know there's been a little bit of
controversy about and i have i have a
special guest with me kfa karen how are
you
i'm great thanks for having me nice to
see you yes it is so good to have you
here everyone and everyone knows that
you are the co-host of the wednesday
edition of legal af how many yeah you
guys have been doing the episode how
many episodes have you guys done for
this wednesday it's been it's been
several weeks hasn't it yeah it has i
think i think we're up to maybe 13 or 14
i'm not exactly sure but around that
number so we're get we're getting there
that's fantastic that's fantastic so
everyone out there uh no the midas
mighty it is a
is part of our fan base too you know you
know we we we come to you from the the
midas touch facebook page and we are
proud partners of mind as touch so we
have a lot of the midas mighty so they
know exactly who karen is and and if you
don't catch the wednesday edition you
can go to the midas touch facebook page
and watch
live and live chat with pope hoc because
we've had po poc on the show and karen
during during the show live you can you
can chat with him there on the youtube
page or you can catch it out on any of
the uh the podcast directories out there
so catch the special wednesday edition
but karen you have you have a very
special resume
um you used to work in a certain office
it may or may not be the manhattan da's
office is that correct
that is correct yes but you did not work
for the current manhattan d.a is that is
that correct also that is correct i
worked for the two prior manhattan da's
i started under robert morgenthau
and i worked for him for about 15 years
then i left and i went to work for mayor
mike bloomberg of new york city for a
few years and then when when cyrus vance
jr was elected district attorney i began
working for him in 2010 and i stayed
almost till the end of his
administration which was uh he served
three terms so 12 years and he decided
not to run again and and i was his chief
assistant da which is the number two so
i basically helped run the whole office
and um i knew when he wasn't going to
run that uh the new da whoever it would
be would want their own new chief
assistant so i had to decide do i want
to run for da or do i want to
or i have to leave and find a new job
and i made this decision so here i am
and yes that's where i worked well we
are very happy i mean i
there i have mixed feelings i wish you
were in charge over there at the da's
office right now because we have a
little we have a little of a mixed bag
over there um and there's probably
things that you cannot talk about
because there's probably some things
that you do know that we can't reveal
here on the show um but i do want to ask
you about
uh how the manhattan da's work because a
lot of people don't know like how many
terms can you serve how long the term is
because the question is a lot of times
it's like well this brag guy right he
won he won the election and he's decided
at this point there's question rather
he's going to prosecute we've seen
pomerantz uh a special investigator with
the d.a had left
uh the the resignation letter uh had
released it was obvious why everyone
thought they knew why he had left and
and the resignation letter lays it out
there so how long is a term for the da
how does that work
so the d.a so new york city is comprised
of five boroughs manhattan brooklyn the
bronx queens and staten island and each
borough also known as a county has its
own elected district attorney so the
manhattan da's office is exactly that
it's the manhattan district attorney is
the d.a of manhattan and just the island
of manhattan and prosecutes and
investigates crimes that uh involve the
cri the island of manhattan it's a
four-year term and there are no term
limits so robert morgenthau for example
was district attorney for three decades
and you know there haven't been that
many da's and there haven't been that
many manhattan da's uh they've all been
they've all been white men and you know
when you look at the people who are
traditionally prosecuted by the
manhattan da's office and most local
prosecutors it's it's nine out of ten
people of color it's you know
unfortunately and i think at this time
and one of the reasons i decided not to
run was i felt like at this moment in
time it was time for a person of color
and to bring a new perspective into the
district attorney's office and i was
really excited about album bragg at the
time he has an incredible resume and he
has incredible experience and he also
has a really interesting life story
growing up as a black man in new york
city and i felt like it really is time
you know what i what i was doing all
this time was very much old not old
school it was progressive to a point and
clearly it was time for a new
perspective but i'm starting to wonder
whether he
whether my support for him was uh
you know was was was warranted i mean
there were a couple of good candidates
he was one of the ones i didn't endorse
him necessarily but i was rooting for
him you know i love the office it's i
would say it's probably the best
prosecutor's office in the country it's
always had a great reputation and
really rooting for him to do things
differently and to bring a new
perspective but i have to say he's made
some decisions that are really
disappointing
and i'm hearing from people in the
office they're not happy and people are
leaving in droves
and
i'm i'm very concerned
so what what can be done about this
because i had michael popock your your
your co-host uh on the wednesday edition
of legal af i had him on the show and we
asked him a few questions about um what
is what power does the governor have
because from what i understand and in
most states i think it is this way that
the governor of the state has the power
and the ability to
um basically pull a mulligan if you want
to
refer to it that way with a district
attorney or any attorney or maybe even
assign a special prosecutor so is there
anything that can be done um where we
see the letter from pomerantz and
pomerantz lays it out in very clear
language trump has committed crimes not
like maybe not like possibly
not like uh it could be criminal
activity he's like trump is a criminal
he committed crimes you have to
prosecute him and if you're not i'm
going to leave that's basically what the
letter says so is there anything that
can be done at this point from the
governor anyone else
so there's a couple of things um
the governor could make a referral
to the attorney general's office and the
reason that's important is the attorney
general
who is has a parallel investigation a
civil investigation her name's uh
letitia james she has a parallel civil
investigation uh that was in conjunction
with the manhattan da's office into the
crimes that the manhattan da's office
was investigating so it had nothing to
do with january 6 for example the
manhattan da's office was investigating
the valuation of various properties
either overvaluing or undervaluing
depending on whether they want to pay
taxes less taxes or they want to be able
to have an appraisal and make more get
more money um on the property so you
know that's really what that
investigation was about it's very
discreet and the governor could give
tisch james jurisdiction criminal
jurisdiction over that if she wanted and
she's indicated she's aware of her
of her powers and her authority on on
how she can do that so that is one
possibility another possibility
is um is the feds you know the u.s
attorney's offices and they all have
the u.s attorney's office has criminal
jurisdiction and they could prosecute
this as well you know in my i have a
sort of secret fantasy in my head where
i'm thinking the southern district of
new york which is notorious for being
independent they actually um
tongue-in-cheek call themselves the
sovereign district of new york because
you know they sort of do things
um very innovative and bring cases um in
a way that isn't necessarily uh
the department of justice is slightly
separate from them you know they do
their own thing and they're respected to
do their own thing and trusted and in my
mind i'm hoping they're they're calling
mark pomerantz up who who resigned who
was a special prosecutor and is a former
federal prosecutor and puts him in the
grand jury i mean the work has been done
you know people are frustrated with
merrick garland because he's taking they
say he's taking too long to investigate
the um
the the crimes surrounding the
insurrection january 6 and and other
trump
and trump administration crimes but
investigations take time and you can't
put pressure especially political
pressure on criminal investigations
because that can actually
infect them and and infuse politics into
into criminal investigation and the
minute you put politics in there people
it loses credibility and and and the the
power to prosecute someone really needs
to be independent and separate it's a
separate branch of government and it
really you have to have faith in in the
judicial system and you know i i will i
have to say trump was the first time
ever that i think we we sort of started
to lose faith in the department of
justice because he was in infecting
criminal prosecutions with politics and
i know that
biden and and garland want to bring that
independence and that respect back so
you got to keep politics out of
out of this but but the investigation
that long
several year investigation that the
manhattan da's office was not doing they
did the work they were ready to go into
the grand jury they were ready to bring
indictments so the work is done and and
in my mind i'm wondering whether the
southern district
could call mark palmer ants up and
prosecute the case that he and carrie
dunn and the rest of the team at the
manhattan da's office has put together
all these years and i also think it's it
could be an easier prosecution or at
least an easier indictment because in in
new york state in order to seek an
indictment and you go into the grand
jury you have to put non-hearsay
evidence which means live every every
piece of evidence you put in has to come
from the person giving the evidence so
you could have hundreds of witnesses who
have to come in and testify and tell
what they know and put in their records
and their documents but the feds don't
have that requirement they can put
hearsay into the grand jury so i wonder
and i you know look i'm not a federal
prosecutor i'm not an expert in that but
i'm wondering could they just put mark
pomerantz into the grand jury get an
indictment and then subpoena all of the
records that the manhattan da's office
has and just bring that case
and and that's what i'm hoping is
happening i'm hoping that it's happening
behind the scenes you know i'm i'm the
fact that we don't know about it is okay
and probably a good thing you don't want
leaks coming out of your justice
department or your prosecutor's offices
and so i'm just hoping that that's
what's happening behind the scenes and
we will see a case in short order but
that that's what needs to happen if it's
not
you know i i'm glad you segued into the
department of justice um through the
southern district of new york in
southern district of new york because i
believe there's a lot of federal
districts that are probably quietly
investigating a lot of the trump
shenanigans that not only happened
before he came president but while he
was president and then after he lost the
election i believe there's probably a
federal
um jurisdiction down in georgia that's
interested in some of the fraud that he
committed down there or tried to try to
intimidate election officials down there
i believe that's a federal crime i'm not
sure i'm not a lawyer but you know or a
prosecutor but i i believe that that
possibly could be a federal crime yeah
in that district as well so because i i
am i am at the same level you are about
uh merigorn the department of justice um
here's the thing
it is very authoritarian which scares
the absolute bejesus out of me
when
left-wing people say merrick garland
should just wave his magic wand and
merrick garland should prosecute anyone
and everyone
within five feet of donald trump right
like that's the that's the feeling that
you get and they're really questioning
the institution not so much merrick
garland which is i think um the slow
walk to authoritarianism i mean these
same people who are now complaining
about merrick garland not doing enough
to be an authoritarian figure in the
department of justice were complaining
about bill barr
being an authoritarian figure in the
department of justice and it really is
now i understand that the country is
very
on edge here and has a lot of anxiety
about our democracy
if this stuff continues and people
aren't held accountable not just for
january 6 but the crimes that he
possibly committed and probably
committed with his uh his money washing
machine that is the trump organization
in in new york but also some of these uh
intimidation tactics that he used in
some of these elections during the big
lie
so
if if you could explain to people
because you've been in a prosecutor's
office
why it is so important
for a prosecutor's office like the
manhattan da's or the southern district
of new york or the department of justice
in general
to not say a single peep
about an investigation because if that
invest if certain information gets out
about that investigation it could hurt
it so explain that to us just a little
bit
sure so there's a there's
many reasons why you don't want leaks to
get out first of all
putting together an investigation
depends on having witnesses who are
willing to cooperate
and you have to have people you can
subpoena them but at the same time you
want people to be able to come in and
testify and so if you don't want them to
be intimidated you don't want them to be
afraid you also don't want them to
talk to peop to listen to the news about
um facts
and and suddenly they're going to now
give facts that they heard on the news
that's not the that's not their
their mind their evidence their memory
and that's what it has to be so part of
it is is to preserve the evidence and to
preserve the integrity of the evidence
and so that you make sure you know
sometimes when people in in high profile
uh cases you sometimes like in a murder
case you'll sometimes get some some
people who come in and you know confess
to the crime you know these people have
mental health issues or other problems
and they come and they confess to the
crime and one of the things that um that
law enforcement does is they they test
the person to see do they know facts
about the crime that was never published
in the news you know that was never out
there and if they don't you know that's
one way to easily weed them out but if
they do know something that was never
published it makes you sort of think oh
well maybe i need to look at this person
further so that's one reason why you do
it but another reason you you also you
keep it secret or you keep you know you
keep it um without leaking is you know
sometimes investigations don't end up in
criminal in in crime being um
uh charges being brought
and you know
a lot of people get investigated for a
lot of things that you've never heard
about and
the minute you start
you start sort of saying oh this person
is being investigated for something and
people hear about it that can leave a
stain on a perfectly innocent person's
life forever it literally will follow
them forever and look i'm less concerned
about that with donald trump but in
general in general that is why you
really don't it's not right it's it's
not right that it that that you know um
that that happens and the other thing
too is you know you don't want your car
your case tried in the court of public
opinion you want your your case tried
based on evidence and and when it is
tried in the court of public opinion you
got all these commentators now you got
everyone including me have a podcast and
you know we sit here and we we comment
on everything under the sun
you know it it's we don't know the facts
we don't know the evidence we don't know
any of it and so here we're you know
we're potentially infecting a jury pool
you know that's gonna sit and hear the
case because sometimes you know when you
when you have too much commentary and
peanut gallery that don't don't know all
the facts you know cases take on a
feeling and and and again there's the
presumption of innocence and we still
have to prove our cases beyond a
reasonable doubt to a jury and you don't
want them coming in with a preconceived
notion or a bias or or they can't sit
and be fair because they've heard too
much about it so there's lots of reasons
i'm sure i'm forgetting half of them you
know why
why it's important to um you know to
keep things you know very much um not
just quiet but like you try your case in
court you know prosecutors shouldn't
talk about cases outside of court you
talk about it in court and and that's
where it should happen that's where the
words should happen and that's where the
information should happen and i i feel
very strongly about that
so that that's a that's those are all
really good points
and the the point that of that you don't
want stuff to leak out you don't want
stuff to be political and you don't want
a lot of commentary this is why i've
been saying for a long time that this is
the reason why republicans mitch
mcconnell kevin mccarthy did and donald
trump himself did not want a 911 style
commission uh to investigate the january
6
attack on the capital the insurrection
and the reason why they want it
political they want it out in the open
they wanted uh democrats to have a
political investigation which the the
investigation with the january 6th elect
committee is political it's a political
body it's politicians and they're
investigating it it is a political
investigation and we heard we heard some
noise that possibly the january 6 select
committee was not going to be making
criminal referrals possibly for some
high crimes they're just making
referrals that have to do with their
committee being the contempt charges
like yesterday
we seen that dan scavino and peter
navarro were
advanced they are going to refer
congress is going to refer
those two individuals for contempt of
congress because not only
not only are they not
doing the subpoena thing but they are
actively going out into the public
navarro specifically saying the things
that the january 6 select committee
wants to question them on um and then
he's claiming executive privilege so
there's a lot of working uh going on in
there but do you think that is the one
reason why republicans didn't want am i
right that they didn't want a 911 style
commission because they wanted this to
be political for the reasons that you're
saying is to you know pollute pollute an
investigation from the department of
justice or the southern district in new
york or maybe a district in georgia
where there could be possible election
crimes do you think that's why possibly
that the republicans wanted that i think
it is and i think it's a miscalculation
but what do you think
i don't think they're that smart i mean
you're giving them way too much credit i
hate to say it i think they don't want
it because they don't want the facts out
there
i think they they it's so ugly it's so
bad
and until you it you know
until you read sort of i i just recently
read a 44-page decision
um that judge carter issued in
california
regarding john eastman and um
and whether or not certain documents are
privileged and in order to make that
that ruling he had to see you know under
an attorney-client privilege and and one
of the exceptions is it's part of the
crime fraud exception and
he and to do that he you have to spell
out was a crime committed and so he
spent many many many many pages
basically creating a road map for the
department of justice or anybody else
listening
there was a crime that committed it's
horrific and this is how you prosecute
it and this is how you prosecute the
president and so i i think they don't
want those facts out there and i think
that's why why they're doing doing this
because they're hoping that biden does
sort of what he said he was going to do
which is let's bring us all together and
let's move past it heal the country and
i think they're hoping that the facts
never come out i mean you might be right
i i just i can't imagine that they
that they aren't doing anything other
than panicking that these that the facts
not come out but you are right it does
by them having this you know i have such
mixed feelings about the house
um
about the house select committee uh
doing this investigation and the reason
i have mixed feelings about it is
number one it does infuse politics into
what's potentially a criminal
prosecution and it only hurts a
prosecution
because now it's going to be viewed as
political and it you want you want any
pr first of all i i'm going to make very
clear i absolutely think there should be
a prosecution i'm hoping there should be
a prosecution and i want there to be a
prosecution and i want there to be not
just a prosecution but a conviction
and a successful prosecution so for that
to happen
the worst thing you can do is infect it
with politics it's the thing that will
make every person every potential juror
and every everybody think it's
illegitimate and it's a witch hunt and
you're going to feed into what donald
trump is going to say if he is
prosecuted that it's political because
it came from the house so i'm hoping to
god the house does not make a
quote-unquote referral because making a
referral is not a thing you don't need
it
right like people department of justice
has it right so that's
can i tell you prosecutors will read
something in a newspaper and say oh wow
that's investigative journalism i'm
going to now issue subpoenas and look
into that myself that that's you know
you don't need much to bring a case you
literally you you you could have a
witness tell you about it you could have
a police officer tell you about it or
you can read about it in the newspaper
wait a second you're telling me you're
telling me you could have watched the
january 6 insurrection on tv and you
could bring you could bring uh that case
to a grand jury based on the evidence
that's just out there in the open is
that what you're saying is that you can
start an investigation that way start an
investigation that way yes oh okay okay
so um you don't need a referral so don't
do it because then you infuse politics
into it so i'm hoping to god they don't
do it the other thing that i the reason
i say i have mixed feelings about the
january 6 committee is take a step back
for a minute every single person on that
committee is also
one of the victims of the crime right
many of them were there that day many of
them were attacked were terrified for
their life imagine any other crime any
other case where the jury you pick for
the jury people who are actually victims
of the crime i think think about a rape
case and the the you know the rape
victim is going to be the person sitting
on the jury and
and and listening you know to the
evidence i mean they they can't be
objective you just can't it makes no
sense whatsoever that they're doing this
if you want a prosecution if there's not
going to be a prosecution and they want
to get the facts out there and issue a
report and hold hearings and and
whatever then i get it then you have a
hearing and that's why the 911
commission was was so appropriate
because most of the people who did that
died and you know they they they died in
in the plane crash etc so you know
they're they you couldn't bring a lot of
those prosecutions if any so the people
the public wanted to know what happened
how did it happen
and how did we get to that point and it
made all the sense in the world that you
would have a 911 commission but we are
hoping for a prosecution here and so i
would say to to congress back off you
know
just really just the whole thing about
the referral you know um
i know that that navarro and scavino
there was a referral
because of this being held in contempt
and that is really the only thing that
they should make referrals about are
people who they want to be held in
contempt of congress and that's
appropriate because
because that's something that's
happening in congress you know don't
forget there's there's three branches of
government right you know and separation
of powers you've got you know the the
president's the executive branch um
you've got the judicial branch which is
the judges and you've got congress which
is the legislative branch and and and
the department of justice um
interestingly falls under the executive
branch under the president not under the
judicial branch even though it's you
know it's it's um even though it's it's
part of the same system you know the
court system and so so you know by the
by if you
by not doing what congress wants you to
do the congress is actually the victim
of contempt of congress and so they're
the ones then you know referring or
reporting what happened to the executive
branch and to the justice department who
are the only ones who can actually bring
an indictment and prosecute that and so
you know so that is an appropriate
referral but but the january 6
insurrection that you don't need a
referral it was on tv they know about it
investigate it and if there should be a
crime brought then bring it and if
honest and also if there shouldn't be a
crime brought if someone did not commit
a crime then don't bring it and we
should all live with that and know that
it wasn't about politics that it was
about looking at the facts and doing an
investigation and seeing where the facts
lead and if a crime occurred and you can
prove it beyond a reasonable doubt bring
the case i think you can prove it beyond
a reasonable doubt um
and and you know i i i don't understand
why um
if they don't bring the case but but
that's that's where we are with this
well you know i think the department of
justice uh has has a case um and they've
shown by the many prosecutions that
they've i mean there are people with
their uh cold bare feet on a prison
floor right now um from for the january
6 insurance they've made over 700
arrests right and the other the other
thing that is significant that i think
is evidence that the department of
justice is going to sniff out any crimes
and prosecute and indict anyone uh
rather you know about it or not uh you
being the public um that
the oath keepers had no clue those 11
people had no clue that they were going
to be indicted the day that they were
indicted
enrique tario the the leader of the
proud boys no clue that he was going to
be indicted so much so that the guy was
almost naked when he was arrested so
this idea that we ha we have to know
what merit garland department of justice
is doing
to make sure that they're held
accountable is kind of ridiculous the
other thing too that i just want to add
is that merrick garland isn't actually
in charge of prosecuting in people in
the jurisdiction of dc he is the
attorney general but he is not the
prosecutor in dc i think a lot of people
get that confused and maybe maybe i'm
wrong to point that out but i actually
think that is a significant thing that
merrick garland actually has as the
attorney general he is the tippy top of
the department of justice and there is a
lot of other cases that are going on
other than just the cases that have to
do with january 6. so inside the
jurisdiction of dc which is very busy
i've heard they've tried to hire several
hundred more attorneys to try to try
these cases uh to get them through the
system because there is so many cases
that are being brought
and it's
it it's kind of just the irony is like
oh they're not doing anything but
they're hiring like hundreds of
attorneys to get these cases through the
court system but merrick garland isn't
the actual prosecutor in the dc
jurisdiction he is
the boss of the person who would
prosecute those cases is that correct
that is correct every jurisdiction has
its own united states attorney appointed
by the president confirmed by the senate
and merrick garland is the boss right
right so he doesn't actually bring those
cases speaking of dc
this case of the secret service
this morning that is kind of like
blowing up on twitter and these videos
of this i want to play real quick here
let me see if i can play this video can
you you can see this here this is a
video of a couple fbi agents
i was trying to sound off walking out of
a building called crossing
um and i guess it's a luxury apartment
building in dc
but apparently what has happened is that
there was a several
i i guess they were uh phony dhs agents
is what they were posing as
and i i don't know if i guess they were
renting apartments for secret service
agents that possibly could have um been
protecting the first lady i i'm not sure
what what do you know about this story
so far
so this is just a crazy
banana story that i've i think we don't
know enough because
either these are real
secret you know i asked some people in
law enforcement this morning because i
was like this can't possibly be true and
and i think
there's a possibility that they might
actually be
um
they might actually be agents of some
sort so let's i think we have because if
they're not this is a really really
dangerous story so there's two
individuals um who were posing as
federal agents and it depends on who you
ask what agents they were posing as some
super secret something or other they
were living in an apartment building
where many
fbi agents secret service agents and dhs
agents live in washington and they seem
to have a lot of money and so they're
being funded you know by renting these
expensive apartments and um and having
access to things that i don't know who's
funding them so at first i was like this
is either a foreign government or a
terrorist group or
it could you know be both and be the uh
republican party frankly which you know
right right domestic terrorists domestic
terrorism exactly exactly i mean and
that's what i mean you know um
and you know look there are there are
there are parts of my
my leanings that have always been both
liberal and conservative and i you know
used to very much um before trump you
know
not be so anti-republican party but
what's happening now
and and many of the people in as ben
myself calls it the gqp and the q anon
you know branch of the republican party
i think there is a domestic terrorism
element too
uh to that anyway these these guys
had access to
uniforms
to badges to guns
to
identifications to cars with lights to
all the bells and whistles to all the
secret equipment to all the things that
if you were law enforcement you would
have access to i mean a lot you know
you watch tv you see people posing as
law enforcement they might have bought a
badge a fake badge off of you know
off of the internet somewhere or they
might get a uniform off the internet
somewhere
to have all of the things that these
individuals had is sort of staggering to
have the resources they had to rent the
apartments and um to you know keep up
this charade that they were actual
federal agents the fact that they were
so convincing that they could get close
to the secret service agents that were
guarding the first lady of the united
states that's what blows my mind like
that's the part like holy sh because
really it points out more than um the
question of who these people are
is like
what is the seek like there's been so
many dings in the secret services
reputation over really the last couple
decades um we've seen when obama was
president there was several jumped in
they went into the white house i mean
there's just been time after time after
time where the secret service has really
damaged their reputation but that is
probably one of like
people guarding the first lady are
compromised here by these
by who knows who right and that's
probably the most the craziest part
about the story that they were
convincing secret service agents don't
you think at this point
i actually that's why i'm stunned by the
story that's why i think there's a
possibility that maybe they actually are
agents because i i can't believe it
otherwise otherwise where did they get
all of this how did they do it how did
they know the language that you speak
you know the terms that you use the
training kind of you know things that
you needed how do they have access to
all of the law enforcement memorabilia
and bells and whistles and you know
identifications and and tools and toys
and things that they have how did they
have all of that how did they have the
money to rent i think it was like forty
thousand dollars yeah it's like seven
thousand dollars a month for because
this is not like um like a cheap
apartment building this is a luxury
apartment building there's and there
were two and there were two of them
there were two of them right well here
are two people let me show you a video
here this is a report of i guess a
neighbor it doesn't show his name or his
face but he talks a little bit here um
about the the suspects the the supposed
phony dhs agents the two individuals
charged today
um they were they were pretty cool you
know um
they they told us they were special
police so we thought they were actually
police officers walking through the
building with weapons and everything
what did you think when you saw that
they were in person
as federal agents
well i didn't we didn't know
so there's there's a resident he goes on
to say in this um his little interview
here he goes on to say that he would
they would sit by the pool and hang out
and that's that's kind of how they got
to know him i guess is that these people
did not have any just they didn't have
any suspicion now there is another
interview of a resident that was very
leery of these two gentlemen um and and
they go on to say i guess that kind of
creeped the women out or something in
the building you know i'm not sure if
there was like an incident or something
but they're there apparently is a couple
different views of the residents in the
building of who these people were
but it just
uh because i hear what you're saying
about
maybe these are really agents but
they're not acting in their official
capacity could that be what's going on
is they are agents of the government
somewhere because we've seen during the
january 6 uh i call it the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup um
where
the law enforcement officers
former officers former military and were
part of the insurrection they were part
of trying to overthrow the government of
the united states do you think maybe
that's what's going on here is that
they're actually agents they're just not
acting in their capacity they're acting
against their oath
or their former agents and that's how
they have access to
all of the memorabilia the language the
you know they know how to talk you know
there's there's certain sort of
things that you would say and do and
places that you've been and trainings
that you've had and you know ways to
kind of bond and
and and
get credibility and legitimacy with
other agents to convince them that you
are who you are so maybe their former
you know former agents but i still think
there's more there is more to this story
and i don't know what it is you know is
it gonna turn out that it's being funded
by you know by somebody who who was
motivated by getting close to biden and
you know the first lady was it being
motivated by you know some sort of
domestic terrorism or a foreign
government you know like like the
russians you know is it
or is it or is it going to turn out that
you know
maybe i watched too much television but
maybe this is all part of some undercut
you know maybe they're so deep
undercover that they were getting blown
and they had to go through with the
undercut you know they had to continue
the the ruse and arrest them and it
sounds like a really good movie this
sounds like a really good movie by the
way there's something is going to come
out there's more to the story because
there is just no way that two guys you
know decided that i'm going to be this
and and be as successful as they are
because the secret service they do a
really really good job yes they've had a
few
um a few things as you point out that
have called it into question but you
know
they a lot of i don't think you know
most presidents don't die or don't get
shot at and
they do a really good job at protecting
them and they do a lot of other things
too other than just um
protect you know that's one of the
things they do is protect you know the
president and and the family and former
presidents which you know they do they
do have a whole other um aspect to them
that investigates financial crimes and
cyber crimes and you know they're it's
an excellent organization and
and i you know so
i don't know i don't know how it
happened and i know that they're going
to do a deep investigation into both who
these guys are but also how it happened
and and we'll see from there but i i
just this is a story to watch for sure
well as this develops we'll we'll have
you back on as we get more news and i
really appreciate you joining us before
before we head out here um we're gonna
head into the second hour here we
appreciate karen coming and joining us
today to talk about these topics tell us
where we can find you tell us about
about the the wednesday edition of legal
af right but before you go so everyone
knows where to find it where to find you
and how to how to follow you on twitter
is is an important thing here thank you
so yeah so i go by kfa legal i was i was
so impressed you were able to uh
pronounce my name by the way so oh yeah
yeah cause it's not easy honey practice
i practice yeah so i figured you know a
lot of people in my old job called me
kfa because it's just so much easier so
i just kept it and so kfa legals who i'm
on twitter and i'm a co-host of legal af
wednesday edition you can um you know
catch us through youtube through twitter
through midas touch you know wherever
you get your podcast but you know follow
the minus touch and you know they're
they're amazing the midastouch.com and
the midas mighty as you gave them a
shout out or they're really the fuel
that keeps us all going because they're
just so loyal and wonderful and
you know it makes it all worth it so
thank you so much for having me well
shout out to the midas mighty and um i'm
going to i'm going to let pope because
i've had poebach on pop kind of invented
the pope popping yeah but um i i i have
po poc on i'm gonna you know i'm gonna
have to text him and tell him hey popock
you know you're a great guest but this
kfa oh my gosh
she may she may just take your seat at
the table here for the the tony michaels
podcast uh legal af correspondent i
guess we could call it that maybe i
appreciate it you know but i need a
catchy freight like the po pop pocket or
whatever it's called poke pokemon
it's a catchy phrase yeah i know what
watch this watch
so there's here's the there's the the
sound that we do when popock comes on
but you know but maybe we'll come up
with a graphic and some kind of catchy
yeah exactly i think he's a great he's
great he's a great he is he he is he
he's a great co-host he's a great guest
uh we always everyone always loves to
have public on it and go subscribe to
the youtube channel you can go watch all
the po poc poppins if you want over
there on our youtube channel go to the
tony michaels podcast on youtube and
you'll find them there thank you very
much for joining us for having please
come back when this secret service story
develops the d.a story develops it's
crazy we'll have you back as this
develops everyone stick around we'll be
right back after these messages thank
you karen take care
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[Music]
[ __ ] up welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
so we're already getting suggestions
on the kfa
segment
you know we we do the po pog
she says um she says the kfa
ketchup
you know maybe the kfa ketchup oh see
look at there irony i still have her her
banner up
it was it was so nice to have
uh kfa karen friedman agnipoglow
on the show well it's fantastic to have
her inside into the
the manhattan da's office again she was
number two under psy vance
so um
a gavel for kfa maybe kfa gavel gaveling
for kfa
robin says here um mj wants me to
remember or remind everyone
that that k fans
are
kfa fans you see that you see cave fans
uh thank you karen for coming on the
show we really appreciate your insight
into these topics and your unique
experience in the
manhattan da's office
we are we are into the second hour now
on the tone of michael's podcast again
reminding everyone out there we're on
youtube twitter twitch every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific
if you're out on the west coast
and we're on youtube twitter and twitch
streaming live
just go to thetonymichaels.com you can
find all the links there or go to
youtube and just search the tony
michaels podcast you will find us on our
channel
speaking of that we also broadcast on
the midas touch facebook page we're on
the books of face folks
the books of face
so go over there and uh follow my stats
you can follow me on facebook instagram
twitter
but don't forget don't forget to follow
the podcast on twitter at
tonymichaelspod
you can follow me and gabe also on
twitter at the tony michaels and i am
gabe sanchez my co-host and executive
producer
i don't know if he's going to be joining
us today or not
we went a little long with karen that
was fantastic i'm glad we got to talk
about those topics
um but go follow us on at tony michael's
pod because as you guys know we do the
bonehead of the week every single week
and boy are there some boneheads to pick
from this week
holy moly
looks like marjory taylor green may make
a reappearance uh this week on bone head
of the week so if you want to vote
for three-toed marge as i call our hoof
foot green here
uh don't don't forget to go follow at
tony michael's pod we will release the
bonehead of the week poll sometime today
for you to vote and then tomorrow in the
second hour you know every friday in the
second hour of the show we go through
your vote your vote on the bone end of
the week poll
me and gabe break down why those people
appeared on bone of the week and we
break down
your choice
your vote the winner
of the bone end of the week so don't
forget to to go vote on the money of the
week we appreciate that
you know we need really we got a lot of
topics to cover here on the [ __ ] list
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trinity trends today
apparently nancy pelosi is planning on
going to taiwan uh of course we have the
secret service but we also have the
capitol police in the news with marjorie
taylor green just another reason to put
that [ __ ] on the bonehead of the week
paul gosar was trending earlier of
course justice katanji brown jackson and
we're gonna get a vote for her to be the
first
black female the first black woman on
the supreme court of the united states
today the most qualified nominee to ever
be voted on
in the senate to be confirmed to the
united states supreme court
as a justice today we should have that
this afternoon i believe i'm not sure
exactly when they plan on taking that
vote but i guess it's this afternoon we
also have some
news at the un's human rights council
china apparently
has voted to not strip away the voting
rights of russia in the human rights
council so let's do this
let's go to the [ __ ] list roundup and
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast
we are reached the segment in the second
hour where we round up all the tweety
tweets and attorney trends of the day
the [ __ ] list roundup
oh boy a lot of stuff to round up today
a lot of garbage a lot of stuff to dunk
into the trash
uh specifically six members of the house
of representatives
who voted to not investigate war crimes
or to have an investigation into war
crimes because republicans don't want to
investigate putin war crimes because
those are war crimes that they would
commit
just like in tennessee
just like in tennessee they're trying to
hide that they were wanting to marry
little girls that's right they were
trying to give away their child brides
in tennessee and as soon as everyone
found out and we started yelling and
screaming into the microphone i was
yelling and screaming for the first 20
minutes i think 20 30 minutes yesterday
i don't know if you if you noticed and i
tweeted about it a lot yesterday and i'm
going to continue these kid diddlers are
not we're not gonna let up
they didn't just stop being kid diddlers
because they decided that the bill would
be unpopular
no not gonna happen
we are gonna continue to pound this drum
we got the 2022 midterms coming up do
you want a bunch of people who want to
marry your 12 year old daughter running
and winning in congress do you
do you want people who are in control of
gas price that's what they're saying oh
joe biden and the democrats are making
gasoline so high
the bread and milk is so high you go to
tiffany's and the bread at tiffany's is
so high you remember this is [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
that the former guy donald trump the
cheeto dust mobster said i don't know
last week or the week before who can
[ __ ] keep up with this [ __ ]
saying that the bread there's no bread
at tiffany's that's what he said i go to
the hardware store and they're out of
bread at the hardware store what a
[ __ ] idiot
guess what
we are not gonna forget this [ __ ] we're
not gonna forget
and let me ask you a question this is
the question you need to pose to
everyone out there
you talk about messaging
we talk about it here all the time
if one of your one of your people around
you your family your friends whoever
co-workers like gash prices biden's
fault vote for republicans you just say
look you want the people who want to
marry children
you want a bunch of [ __ ] pedophiles
you want republican kid diddlers in
charge of the gas prices
you want republican kid diddlers in
charge of the economy
you want republican kid dealers in
charge of infrastructure
you want republican kidnappers in charge
of healthcare that's what you want get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] i
don't want pedophiles anywhere near
anything in charge of anything i don't
care what it is
don't want them in charge of anything
that's where we're at folks
not one republican not one
i didn't hear him did anyone else find a
statement yesterday of a republican in
front of a microphone
denouncing
denouncing the pedophile bill in
tennessee
i didn't hear one
not one not a mitt romney not a susan
collins not a lisa murkowski
none of those
so you damn sure well know that the
fascist the the full-on fascists in the
party didn't say a goddamn thing
they were just like oh no it was a
clerical error we're gonna change it to
18. wink
wink wink just forget just forget we did
the whole pedophilia bill thing just
forget about that
just we don't actually want to marry
your children we just said we want to
mirror your children
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
let's go to the timeline i want to show
you a few things here on the timeline
it's very important here
here is
another video bad company had it here he
says who lives at the crossing let me
make this a little bigger here
there you go
now that company says who lives at the
crossing that's a good question i wish i
could come up with the answer to that
question is there is there prominent
politicians
are there
lobbyists who lives at the crossing this
is where the crossing is where
we seen the
uh the fake phony dhs agents or whatever
the hell it is me and kfa we're talking
about
um here here is uh some fbi agents these
are actual fbi agents walking into and
you can see they're wearing gear here
they're walking into the crossings the
building the luxury apartments and
they're like seven thousand dollars a
month to rent or something like this
isn't just any old apartment building
they got like a private pool and all
kinds of [ __ ]
it's a it's a luxury apartment
so that bad company asks who lives at
the crossing which i think is a good
question uh maybe we'll find that out
more as the days tick on a karen
speaking of kfa she tweeted this morning
desantis versus disneyland mickey mouse
will han will win hands down hopefully
this will finally be his downfall
uh i believe so
we talked about this yesterday that ron
desantis
this this is the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
where they want to sexualize your kid's
gender same [ __ ] in tennessee it's weird
it is [ __ ] weirdo
kid diller type [ __ ] where they want to
sexualize your kids gender and they want
to marry your children it's [ __ ]
weird
here you want to hear you want to hear
here's a clip from yesterday
and meanwhile in tennessee we have a
bill where a rapist family can sue a
woman for being raped i'm not [ __ ]
you it's time to use messaging to win
the 2022 midterms folks it's time not
not next month not the month after not
the month before the midterm now is the
time to fight the fight that these
fascists want to fight they're gonna win
on policy for the time being don't get
discouraged that's what they want you to
do is to get discouraged about the
policy losses like in florida the don't
say gay bill they won that policy and
ron desantis that nazi bigot in florida
signed the don't say gay bill and now
now is picking a fight with disney
because disney knows it's wrong not
because disney is some kind of woke
company disney ceo said you're right i
should stand with equality and equity
for all and that's what they're doing
and that's the fight that ron desantis
is fighting against is equality inequity
and that is the fight that ron desantis
is fighting against when he fights
disney disney's saying we stand for
equality inequity
and rhonda santa's like no
you're woke and you're a piece of [ __ ]
if you stand with equality and equity
you sons of [ __ ] and i want to play a
video for you here
and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
candace owens what a what a [ __ ]
weirdo this is this is a weird [ __ ]
video let's go through it
what we just examined is a mentally
unstable adult predator who has access
to children so she just showed a teacher
who is a of the lgbt community i believe
is the clip she showed before this
but this [ __ ] [ __ ] goes on to say
[ __ ] about disney
that is that is
clearly
cooked up in the mind
of a maniac our children and there is
only one kind of people who don't see it
that way and those are
other predators
like disney a company which focuses its
content exclusively on children
she has come to the realization
that disney as a company
focus its entire entire company
on on
on content for children now that's not
even [ __ ] close to true number one i
don't know if anyone out there i'm sure
a lot of parents out there have disney
plus if you don't
you're not with the times because don't
talk about bruno is like the the most
popular song everywhere you can't go
anywhere without hearing
someone humming let's talk about brute
don't talk about bruno
not one [ __ ]
i
i can't tell you how many times a day
that song enters into my life i have
children but you don't just have dead
children it's a catchy song it's a
catchy song it's a great movie by the
way
but only for children you're telling me
star wars and marvel
that's only for children candace owens
you are a dumb [ __ ]
you are such a stupid [ __ ] idiot
that you think that disney the only
thing that disney does
is for children
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
no one no one who knows anything about
disney other than other than mickey
mouse as the flagship
knows
that disney doesn't just do content for
kids you [ __ ] bonehead quickly
announced that they are going to fight
florida legislators on behalf of these
child groomers in the classroom
and that that's the other thing that
they do right they they're they're
projecting their grooming i have never
never i mean i've heard the word
pedophilia i've heard child molester
i've heard all these things
but the one thing that i've never really
come across
in my days
is the word groomer now a lot of the
lgbt community has run into this this
this word a lot
i've had a lot of people um
i've watched a lot of people and i've
had some people dm me that this word
groomer is really attached to lgbtq
community um
members and allies even but the
you remember back speaking of another
[ __ ] bonehead that we just talked
about marjorie taylor green standing on
stage at a nazi rally excuse me a trump
rally a nazi rally saying that steve
excuse me pete buddha judge and his
husband we're gonna go into little girls
bathrooms that's the groomer thing
that's the nonsense right that's the
[ __ ]
that they sexualize gender
and they sexualize
your orientation
literally because it has the word sex in
it they sexualize it all and they think
gender is sexualized because the word
sex and gender kind of share the same
one of the same definitions right
but what does [ __ ] gender have to do
with anything about sex if you think
about it
if you get a man and a woman who are
married and you start talking about oh
yeah bill and and and tammy they're
they're married you don't immediately
think about sex right
but these [ __ ] weirdos as soon as as
soon as you say yeah tom and john they
they're married they have two kids
they're like oh my god i mean they
immediately they hear they hear lgbtq
in any form or fashion
they immediately go straight to sex like
you know that a lot of people who are
married are married because they love
each other i mean they they probably
have sex but
that's not the only reason why they're
married that's not the only reason why
human beings partner with each other not
the only [ __ ] reason you [ __ ]
weirdos
apparently it is for them
they will demand that these people like
the woman that we just showed you these
people you notice that phrasing these
people
has a right to speak to your child about
her partner's trans feminist whatever
that even means
has the right to what be a be a trans
feminist
so what candace owens is saying here is
she that person whoever she's talking
about has no right
no right to be a trans feminist in this
country absolutely no right and we
should stop her from being that
the [ __ ] are you talking about
as if that wasn't bad enough a private
meeting amongst disney's top executives
recently leaked the animation director
oh my god very clearly that disney has
been quote so welcoming to my not at all
secret gay agenda and i'm sure that's
exactly what she said
quote
yeah
it turns out yeah
at the very end listen listen to the
very end right here
it turns out it wasn't ursula or
maleficent let's listen
right here
yeah
yeah
yeah that's that that's an indication
that everything she just said is a
[ __ ] lie
it turns out it wasn't ursula or
maleficent captain hook or even scar on
the lion god
nope the greatest disney villain of all
time is disney itself yeah disney itself
it goes all the way back
to walt
what the [ __ ]
boycott them every park every show every
coloring book
now i do have to say i am not against
them boycotting disney by the way not at
all [ __ ] no
let me let me give you a situation here
imagine a place that you could go
that had fantastic rides
that that was a great experience right
your kids loved it and there wasn't a
trump humper within within a hundred
miles
that would to me would be the most
magical place on earth
because parents allow me to make this
part perfectly clear to you yeah what
will follow this the intentional and
overt confusion and sexualization of our
children in the classroom is you're
sexualizing their gender dummy
you're sexualizing their gender anyone
who has a kid out there and candace
owens i don't know if she has a kid or
not probably [ __ ] not
everyone who has a kid out there a
little kid out there has questioned
their their gender their genitalia
because they don't know
a little child a little child
has no idea all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
stereotypes
that conservatives place on gender they
have no idea no clue just like they have
no idea about racism they have no clue
they're taught all this [ __ ] you dumb
[ __ ]
you're not born knowing oh i'm a boy and
boy should like this or i'm a girl and
girls shouldn't that's not that's not
how it works
see you're taught these things and
normally a parent has to explain
to a child what the difference is
between the genders and it has nothing
to do with sex candace owens you [ __ ]
weirdo obvious
pedophilia is around the corner yeah you
guys will allow them for one second to
convince
yeah it is real it is the slope is real
this projection here that she's that
she's projecting on to us is [ __ ] is
is
is astonishing it's absolutely
astonishing and this is what they do
this is what fascists do
is they continue to make pedophilia
a constant
word in their mouth so that way it's
like well
well when they pass a bill in tennessee
to make sure they can marry children
they can marry eight-year-olds they're
like well democrats do it right that's
the whole purpose well it's normalized
on the quote-unquote other side by those
other people so we can do it right
that's what they're doing
that's what they're doing when they do
this nonsense
i mean if you want to boycott disney go
boycott disney but to claim that disney
is some kind of part of the pedophile
cabal you are a dumb [ __ ]
disney is part of the prophet cabal in
this country
they bought [ __ ] 20th century fox
marvel
they bought lucasfilms you are a stupid
[ __ ] idiot if you think they're part
of the pedophile cabal the republican
party they're part of the profit cabal
corporations you dumb [ __ ] we must not
give these freaks and predators so much
as one
inch
yes we should not we should not give
them one inch so let's keep them on
blast let's make sure everyone keeps
knowing that these that these republican
kit diddlers are out there and they're
not going to stop
they're not going to [ __ ] stop
um
speaking of kid diddlers and republican
kid diddlers let's um let's play
uh joe here has um a clip from jamie
raskin destroying the kid diddler
uh marjorie taylor green she's a
projectionist by the way she said mitt
romney susan collins and lisa murkowski
are pro-pedophile to vote for a judge
who sentenced pedophiles to federal
prison sentences i don't know i i can't
figure out how they keep saying that kbj
judge brown jackson is pro-pedophile
when she sentenced pedophiles to prison
to federal prison they're sitting in
federal prison right now the people she
sends it doesn't make any sense she
didn't let him out of prison she put him
in prison you dumb [ __ ]
uh joe says don't bring a marjorie
taylor green to a jamie raskin fight
it will never go well for you never uh
let's listen to jamie raskin here and
see what he says
the general lady i think said something
about the russian hoax or
russian collusion i accept the heckling
mr speaker that that's all right
because if she wants to continue to
stand with vladimir putin and his brutal
bloody invasion against the people of
ukraine she is free to do so
[Music]
donald trump that is her prerogative but
please do it on your own time
forth with he says
uh jamie raskin
jamie raskin
oh my god you are the flame thrower of
the house my friend
keep going on the floor of the house
and torching
these republican kid diddlers
that are the republican party
okay let's uh um there is uh here we go
here we go here jack has another video
of marjorie to either green you're just
uh completely getting dismantled this is
the part before he lays into her let's
watch what she said when he lays into
her government
but somehow the communists here in
charge
forgotten or not
purposefully
abusing the constitution and what this
this body of congress is supposed to do
um here's the thing is they try to overt
turn the constitution that she's talking
about they tried to stop
the house of representatives from
constitutionally certifying the vote
of the president united states ahead of
the executive branch it really is
[ __ ] dumb
it's just really [ __ ] stupid that we
have to listen this morning and of
course jamie raskin
whisper
oh that's hilarious mayo says jamie
raskin is my hero yeah thank you mayo of
course
he's
he's getting on the top of the list uh
for everyone's favorite pick and for
possible a presidential run oh ty ross
has some um interesting news here uh on
her occupy democrats uh uh article
apparently the oath keepers didn't get
the memo that hiring a previously
suspended attorney who spent his days
retweeting kevin sorbo may not be the
best move well they [ __ ] around and
now they're finding out the latest at
occupy democrats um apparently the oath
keepers
attorney defense attorney for january 6
has been disbarred um so that's
that's some breaking news maybe we'll
have dakota adams on uh next week to
talk about
uh possibly uh stuart rhodes losing his
attorney uh one other video i want to
play here before i go to the tweety
tweets and tringers because i do want to
get back to marjory taylor green
and the capitol police here is dr oz
pretending like he knows how to grocery
shop and i really want to break this
video down because this guy is such a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] what a phony what
a [ __ ] fraud and let me let me show
you
this guy is how he's a bonehead and a
[ __ ]
i thought it was a grocery shopping i'm
at work nurse and my wife wants some
vegetables for crudite right she wants
some vegetables for crew today oh well
speak populism there dr oz you're really
talking to the majority of the country
when they know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
when in the [ __ ]
did the republican party the kid
diddlers decide that crudite is a
popular a popular dish not hamburgers
and hot dogs
what the [ __ ]
so yeah there's a broccoli there's a
broccoli two bucks two bucks a ton of
broccoli yeah not a ton of broccoli
that's not a ton of broccoli at all i
mean that's only like three days worth
for somebody
there's some asparagus four dollars yeah
four dollars that's only that's only
about of eight helpings of asparagus
carrots
oh look at that look at that small bag
of carrots oh my god that small bag of
carrots there's no way anyone can make
12 meals out of that that's four more
dollars that's ten dollars ten dollars
ten dollars for all those vegetables
what a [ __ ] idiot then watch what he
does and then
we need some guacamole that's yeah
because you can't make guacamole there
oz you can't make it at all you got to
pull it up
this is how you can tell this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] fake
this is how this [ __ ] is fake four
dollars more four dollars for guacamole
because he can't make it then watch what
he does here hey
she loves salsa yeah salsa there
six dollars six dollars for salsa and
you can't make salsa either [ __ ] you
can make whatever that dish is that you
were talking about but you can't make
you can't make [ __ ] jesus christ must
be a shortage of salsa guys that's
twenty dollars for kurute and this
doesn't include the tequila
twenty dollars for crudite you know what
that is do you know every american every
american out there every average
american knows what credit is right i
have no idea what the [ __ ] this is no
[ __ ] clue i don't know
and it has to do with tequila
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
and the thing is here if you look at
this
look at all the [ __ ] look he's got
he's got a whole arm full
full of vegetables here like
two people could eat this amount of
vegetables for like three [ __ ] days
and someone makes a good point it's per
pound he obviously doesn't know how to
[ __ ] grocery shop and neither has
says it's per pound
what a [ __ ] bonehead
what a bonehead
it really is it really is flabbergasting
flabbergasting
that these people think
think that we're not we're not smart
like look i and here's what i tweeted
let me show you what i tweeted because
he blames it on joe biden in the end i
don't need to play that part he blames
it on joe biden i'm gonna give ron greta
here because he posted this video
uh dr know nothing here
i said joe biden
the godfather of the the broccoli cabal
[Laughter]
because he blames the broccoli praises
on joe biden again let me ask you a
question would you rather have democrats
in charge of the broccoli prices or a
bunch of [ __ ] child pedophiles who
want to marry children in charge of
broccoli prices which would you rather
have huh
i don't know i i would choose the people
who don't want to don't want to marry my
my daughter
my 10 year old 8 year old 12 year old 14
year old daughter i would prefer that
those people had nothing to do with the
price of anything
i said cook hot dogs and macaroni you
[ __ ] that's what the rest of people do
in this country who can't afford food
they buy [ __ ] food they buy [ __ ] food
that makes them fat that's how we've got
a problem in this country because people
are broke and poor
and they buy things like hot dogs
chicken hamburger they mix it in with
[ __ ] like i don't know pasta
because it's cheap and it can go far
don't be do
homemake your guacamole there
dr fraud [ __ ] idiot uh thank you
midas lisa for the
for the uh
she said ken for conan of the week i
think you mean bonehead right lisa or
i'm not sure if it's conan
uh minus lisa and midaskin are always in
the chat um
recommending each other for the uh for
i like that you guys go back and forth
thank you for the super chat if you guys
if you guys want you can go to uh
youtube you can follow us
and you can come into the chat and you
give us a super chat or super sticker we
always appreciate all the help
and and all the uh
support that you can give
maybe one day midas ken will work his
way on the bonehead of the week poll uh
thank you mind us lisa all right let's
let's go back to the trendy trends and
the tweety tweets here uh i believe i
believe that means well yeah i think we
want to go to the because i want to get
to this capitol police thing have you
seen this
marjorie taylor green called the capitol
police on jimmy kimmel i'm not [ __ ]
you
i'm not kidding she she
she wants the capitol police to
investigate or arrest jimmy kimmel for
making a joke on his
on his late night show let's see if i
can find it here did it get did it go
off i i gotta
because she's probably gonna be the bone
end of the week so
we gotta play this let me see if i can
find it here
see if i can find this
capital
capital police now here it is there it
is okay let's go back here
there it is okay here's the uh eric
swalwell of course at the very top
marjorie taylor green tweeted this
threat of violence against me by jimmy
kendall has been filed at the capitol
police she called the cops on jimmy
kimmel
[Laughter]
you cannot make this [ __ ] [ __ ] up
marjorie hookfoot green called the cops
on jimmy kimmel for doing a joke
um of course
let's watch the joke and you know what
the crazy part is she thinks it's so
egregious she posted it on twitter
underneath her tweet that are uh in the
house like marjorie taylor green this
one clan mom is especially upset with
the three republican senators who said
they'll vote i'm gonna have to warn you
that probably when we uh replay this on
on youtube you're probably not gonna
hear this sound so you're gonna have to
go find this clip
and the reason why is because um you
know they they're gonna they're gonna
copyright me because it is jimmy kimmel
so they're gonna want the copyrights of
this clip so you're probably not gonna
hear this clip well yes on judge katanji
brown jackson who's nominated for the
supreme court she tweeted murkowski
collins and romney are pro-pedophile
they just voted for kbj wow where is
will smith when you really need him huh
come on that's a good will smith joke
that's a good [ __ ] joke that's
hilarious that's hilarious
um so she tweeted it and she tweeted
that she called the cops on jimmy kimmel
and the eric smallwell here tweets sorry
later sorry lady you voted to defund the
capitol police that's the thing here
they always say democrats are trying to
defund the police
fifa democrats are trying to get rid of
the police marjory taylor green voted
against funding for the capitol police
department that defends the capital i
wonder i wonder if they have an
insurrection that is uh planned
i wonder i don't know maybe that's why
they wanted to fund them i mean why
would they want to marry children in
tennessee if they don't want to marry
children in tennessee
gotta make you wonder right oh my god
oh let's go back to tweet sweets and
jordan jordans i'm sure she's gonna end
up on bone of the week i'm almost
positive of it folks uh let's go to i
want to get to this human rights uh
council it's trending at number seven
now uh the united nations reuters
reports united nations the general
assembly suspended russia from the u.n
human rights council over reports of
gross and systematic violations of abuse
of human rights by invading russia a
russian by invading russian troops in
ukraine um so these war crimes are
starting to
take hold inside the human rights
council where uh we seen uh the other
day
uh the president zilinski of ukraine
encouraged the united nations to tell
russia to [ __ ] off in the human rights
council
so many words right and we had aaron
parnez on yesterday to help the walk us
through this story you should go
subscribe to the youtube channel and you
will find that interview with aaron
on the youtube channel i'm going to post
it later today but it's yesterday's
episode so it's episode number 112
we have the interview with aaron parnez
it's at the very top of the episode
almost so go go check out yesterday's
episode i'll i'll cut aaron's interview
out and post it
as well as karen's
kfa's uh conversation we had today i
also have a rachel bittikoffer
conversation that we had this week that
i gotta cut and put on the youtube
channel so go subscribe uh you can watch
those interviews separate um joe says
here breaking the united nations just
booted putin from the human rights
council it's about [ __ ] time yeah
russia putin on the human rights council
really doesn't make sense now i think
the other news out of here
out of this story is that china
actually voted
um
in support of russia i believe if we can
find it here here's aaron's tweet uh
breaking the united nations suspends
russia from the human rights council
this is great news i think he predicted
this yesterday um i i can't remember i
had to go back and rewatch the interview
but aaron had a prediction yesterday
rather russia would be removed from the
human rights council we talked about it
yesterday um so
go back and watch that interview i'm
gonna have to re-catch it and i again i
will cut it and we will put it we'll
post it on
the youtube page later on today so that
that is the news and i believe russia um
got the support of china in their vote
to be removed from the uh human rights
council at the u.n and just not finding
uh that story the story now is that
uh
that
russia has been removed from the human
rights council which is good news this
is all good news this is a good news in
the effort to take down vladimir putin
uh just like president biden said this
[ __ ] should not be in charge of
anything even a dog catcher
we should be cheering the day that putin
is not
not the leader of russia either you know
i don't know by removal of his people or
an ammo sandwich i don't know we'll see
we'll see if he ends up in a bunker
somewhere
we got news out of uh
the speaker's office today i guess
um she was gonna visit taiwan and just
to expand because taiwan is expanding
sanctions you see kiev independent here
has it uh taiwan expanding sanctions
against russia targets high-tech exports
um so that could be a reason why she was
uh visiting because they were getting
tough on on russia but apparently some
people are saying in the chat that
speaker pelosi has tested positive for
covid so it sounds like maybe her trip
to taiwan if there is one
right wrong or indifferent and we can
debate that at a later
on a later show maybe we're 35 minutes
in the hour i want to get to a few more
topics uh but
it seems like maybe it's going to be
delayed if she is testing positive
for covet is that the actual word
everybody is that that um
that speaker pelosi is testing positive
for
for covid i'm not sure uh we'll we'll
find that uh security council is
trending at number 21 let's see what's
in this one
um
so so um the security council is
um
trending because russia is a permanent
member of the security council
um
but they are no longer a member of the
human rights council so they don't have
a vote in the human rights council which
may or may not be where and i'm not sure
about this where um some
charges could be brought against
vladimir putin in russia
for war crimes uh let's see
um
what else do we have training we have
pogoza earlier i was turning i don't
know if he
still in the trend let's see in the 4u
page
for me
for me the united states senate is
trending probably because they're going
to vote for judge brown jackson
you god damn right um they're going to
be voting for judge brown jack that's
got a good ring to it doesn't it justice
katanji brown jackson
um looks like they're expected to vote
on that let me see if i can go to
c-span real quick
and see if we can
see if they have a
a schedule for that uh it looks like uh
new senate to vote for katangi brown
jackson it looks like it's live right
now
let's go over and see what uh what's
going on over there hang on just one
moment as i bring it up as i bring it up
we might be able to check out
if they're voting currently
um for
katangi brown jackson it looks like they
are
let's
let's go to
the
mitch mcconnell is talking as we speak
let's
insisted the radical left would not be
calling the shots
please
senator commence he insisted the radical
left would not be calling the shots
on his watch
but when it came to one of the most
consequential decisions
a president can make
a lifetime appointment to our highest
court
biden administration
let the radicals run the show
with washington democrats in power
the far left got the reckless
inflationary spending they wanted
the far left has gotten the insecure
border
they wanted
and today the far left will get the
supreme court justice
they want it
the french activists who demand partisan
court packing
attack the justices
and describe our constitution as
trash
made up their minds from the start
of this administration
if a supreme court vacancy should arise
they wanted one nominee
and one one nominee only
judge
jackson
they spent dark money to promote this
person specifically
they pushed her for the d.c circuit
then they badgered justice briar to quit
in february one of these groups
announced judge jackson
would be the nominee
before president biden actually
did make the announcement
so think about that for a moment
the senate has examined judge jackson's
qualifications
with the seriousness and vigor that a
lifetime appointment deserves
unlike when the party's positions are
reversed
the country was not subjected to
uncorroborated smear campaigns
committee boycotts stunts with cardboard
cutouts
or mobs chasing senators
around the capitol
now a few of
our democratic colleagues seem to have
decided in advance they would claim that
judge jackson was treated shabbily
i've heard that script recited
even though it didn't happen
it didn't happen
let's be clear
no nominee before the senate for any
position
deserves a cakewalk
or a coronation
tough questions about a federal judge's
own rulings and statements
are the definition of fair game
my republican colleagues vigorously
inquired she had important new light
on a frequently disturbing
judicial
record so i applaud my colleagues for
focusing on substance
and not following the democrats recent
president he applauds their racism what
a piece of [ __ ] unfortunately what the
sentence process turned up
was disturbing
first the nominee would not okay now
we're going to hear more lies i'm going
to shut this [ __ ] up here's the
thing
uh mitch mcconnell here
is projecting it's more it's more
republican kid diddler projecting
it's the same thing when they accuse ah
the democrat blood sucking cabal with
their pizza place and they're trying to
take your children and their trafficking
and their sexualizing children
they're sexualizing children's gender
and they're trying to marry them
it's more projection when he says ow
dark money paid for kbj and oh the dark
money decided
give me a [ __ ] break
listen they're really [ __ ] pissed off
that they don't get to ask
joe biden's supreme court justice
nominee about the sexual assault
allegations against them because there
are none
they're really [ __ ] pissed off that
they don't get to ask joe biden's
nominee for supreme court justice
about hiding her bigotry behind her
religious dogma because she doesn't
this is why i keep saying this is the
difference between the two [ __ ]
parties it's obvious just in the
questions that they're upset that they
don't get to ask right republicans are
[ __ ] pissed lindsey graham went on
and on and on about all the questions he
couldn't ask a tangie brown jackson
because she hadn't committed sexual
assault she doesn't hide her bigotry
behind her religious dogma he can't ask
her those questions because she doesn't
do any of that [ __ ]
they actually their number one [ __ ]
their number one [ __ ] about judge brown
jackson has to do with their obsession
with child porn
josh hawley and tom cotton and ted cruz
are absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with
child porn
so much so that they accuse
judge brown jackson of somehow being a
marjorie taylor green to pro pedophile
because she sentenced pedophiles to
prison
think about that for a [ __ ] second
judge brown jackson sentenced
indicted and convicted
child pornographers pedophiles chomos to
federal prison
sentences and somehow she's pro
pedophile
if that's pro pedophile then you guys
the republican kid diddlers don't know
what the definition of the word
pedophile is or pro
they just don't it's all projection and
for mitch mcconnell to sit there and say
that the democratic party they pressured
breyer to retire so they could replace
him with some leftists that was paid for
dark money that really does give you
insight into what they did with the last
three nominees
they're telling you what they did
mitch mcconnell is telling you he's like
well we do it god damn we did it for the
last three
so why wouldn't why wouldn't joe biden
and the democrats do it for this one
that's what they're saying that's what i
keep telling you is that that's why
they're that's why they keep saying that
disney's pedophiles and democrats are
pedophiles and anyone who's who's who's
our enemy is pedophiles they're groomers
they keep using this language over and
over and over again it's because when it
comes down to it
they want to be able to say when they
when when they pass laws like marrying
children in tennessee they want to
sexualize kids gender in in
in florida they want to ostracize trans
kids in texas
they're going to probably take away
parents consent for a man to marry a
little girl i'm not [ __ ] you they're
probably going to take they're going to
pass laws or try to pass laws to take
away consent to parents to marry little
girls don't think they're not that's not
next
and here's what they're going to say
oh well the democrats do it the
democrats do it so that's i mean we do
it so why wouldn't they that's the
projection that's where their mind is at
like why wouldn't democrats use dark
money and pressure
justice breyer to retire that's what we
did that's what we do why wouldn't they
do that here's chuck schumer let's
listen to the majority leader
for the senate
for the supreme court
and for the united states of america
today we are here to to vote to confirm
katanji brown jackson as the 116th
justice of the united states supreme
court
now a few days ago i spoke with a group
of eighth graders from cheektowaga new
york
many of them were students of color it
was amazing
when i mentioned that this week we were
confirming the judge
you could see them light up
the unmistakable look in their eyes
one day each
young lady thought to herself i can do
it too
you know it's been a dark two years with
covid
people getting sick and dying many of
whom we knew
stores closing schools shutting their
doors
but even in the darkest times
there are bright lights
today is one of the brightest lights
and let us hope it's a metaphor an
indication
of many more bright lights to come
as i've said over and over again there
are three words that i think best fit
judge jackson
brilliant
beloved
belongs
judge jackson is in every sense and by
all measures a brilliant jurist
she is indeed a brilliant person
by the judge's own telling she first
discovered her calling to the law not in
a classroom or by reading a book or by
talking to lawyers
but by sitting at the kitchen table
next to her dad
filling out a coloring book while her
dad poured through case law
years from now other parents and other
daughters will do the same
and it will be justice jackson's
opinions
that will lay open on the table
the judge's parents
her entire family
should beam with pride
that this day
has come
at every step of her upbringing and
career katanji brown jackson ranked
among the highest of achievers
and look we should take a moment to note
that judge jackson will be the first and
only justice with experience as a public
defender
we're proud of that and america is proud
of that
it will enhance the court's ability
to preserve a basic truth in our country
that all deserve equal justice under the
law
from the privileged to the
impoverished in an imperfect world
the judge considered so many hurdles
so the judge conquered so many hurdles
and today stands as one of the most
experienced individuals ever nominated
to the supreme court for this reason the
judge is also beloved
by individuals and organizations across
the political spectrum
i went through her record carefully and
never did i find one instance of a peer
or colleague or associate say one
negative word about her it was
incredible when we go through these
records you often find someone here and
there who will bad mouth the individual
who knew them not with just judge
jackson the reason why unless we forget
the reason why people are in the minds
of the american people
the reason why uh kentangi brown jackson
is the most qualified supreme court
justice nominee we've ever seen that has
moved her way to the supreme court or
the excuse me the senate floor for the
vote for her nomination to the supreme
court the reason why she is the most
qualified isn't because she's a black
woman it's because she is a black woman
it's because she had to work so [ __ ]
hard she had to earn her spot she earned
every [ __ ] inch every single
millimeter of her qualifications to be
this judge the most qualified judge to
ever sit in a nomination seat in a
judicial and in a senate judiciary
committee hearing
ever
and it's because she had to work so
[ __ ] hard and the reason why she had
to work so [ __ ] hard is because she
is a black woman
in this country
that's why and frankly we should have
more and more and more
black women as judges
and in leadership positions because they
are the most educated they are the most
qualified of any demographic in this
country go look at this go look at the
[ __ ] statistics
they're they're more college educated
than any other demographic and the
reason why is because they have to be to
make it they got to be they can't just
walk their way through life and be a
white male like brett kavanaugh and
sexually harassing sexually molesting
and raping women and drinking beer and
partying and being a half-assed judge
and not doing your work and not doing
the [ __ ] that you got to do and still
become a supreme court justice because
you're a white man let's listen then
again
could have benefited from such a role
model
how many would-be justices lawyers
doctors generals business people
have been lost to history
precisely because their history books
had few if any role models that they
could relate to
we certainly have a long way to go on
the road to true justice
but by confirming judge jackson today
we are taking a bold step forward
towards reaching the full realization of
our country's promise
we will make it far more likely that
girls across america will feel precisely
what judge jackson felt herself when she
was a kid nobody can stop me i can do
this too
i am brilliant to i belong to
for all these reasons increasing the
diversity of the court
has been of one my one of my highest
priorities and one of the highest
priorities of our senate democratic
majority of whom i am so proud
justice jackson is the most important
example but we've been working on this
for over a year
of the 58 senate confirmed federal
judges since we took the majority
three-quarters have been women
two-thirds have been people of color
and it's not just racial or and gender
diversity that matters we have strived
to lift up judges that bring diversity
through their experience
more public defenders in our courts more
civil rights lawyers more election
lawyers
when americans of all walks of life come
before the court
they should have confidence that those
who don the robes have the ability to
walk in their own shoes
to see and understand their side of the
story
and then apply the law properly
according to the facts
one judge at a time one judge at a time
this majority is expanding the
possibility of who merits consideration
to the bench
and i would be remiss
if i didn't acknowledge my republican
colleagues
who joined us on this occasion
over the year
to achieve this goal
in closing
i want to thank chairman durbin for the
beautiful beautifully executing this
nomination process
it was equal parts fair thorough and
expeditious
no easy feat
in this modern senate
i want to thank all of my democratic
colleagues on the judiciary committee
you were just fat
i want to get back to um a little bit of
commentary here as he's closing his
statements here he's going to thank
everyone
here's the thing
this is all on the backdrop right of
uh jeannie thomas clarence thomas's wife
being a q a seditionist
which you know rather we'll actually get
some justice there or not from justice
thomas rather that son of a [ __ ] steps
aside and steps down and we can fill
that seat with another nominee now we
also have the question i think someone
brought it up here in the chat let me
see if i can find it here
someone brought up uh brett kavanaugh's
debt and who paid it
um
it's here somewhere
someone had mentioned it i was watching
sorry there it is uh jazz uh here on
youtube says who paid kavanaugh's debt
i think that's a really good question
maybe if we get the answers to that
there's another supreme court justice
seat that would be open for us to
nominate
now that's two seats
i don't know
maybe that happens maybe it doesn't
i don't know it swings a court doesn't
it in a good direction
who would you want who would you want to
be supreme court justice
if clarence thomas because he's married
and he's part of the q anon sedition
which tried to attempt the cheeto dust
kangaroo and he voted
he voted
to make sure that the records of donald
trump the seditious wreckers that shows
that he tried to commit a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
with john eastman
and others
through his phony executive privilege
claim he voted for it hmm i wonder why
hmm
i wonder why he did that
so clarence thomas if he
we figure that out maybe he gets tied up
in the uh the doj's investigation into
the january 6 cheeto dust kangaroo that
is the insurrection where they try to
attempt to overthrow the government of
the united states and if he's part of
that i would say that he if he doesn't
step down and resign he could be
prosecuted or
or
that he could be impeached
for his his role in the cheeto dust
kangaroo if he had any which come on
give me a [ __ ] break there's no way
that jeannie thomas and clarence thomas
weren't talking about cueing on
conspiracy theories give me a [ __ ]
break
now we get to brett kavanaugh what if we
find out that brett kavanaugh someone
illegally
and paid off his debts for him to become
the supreme court justice i don't know
maybe that's maybe that's impeachable i
think there's probably plenty of [ __ ]
that these [ __ ] republican kid
diddlers have done
the one especially the ones that they
put in the supreme court
racked up our supreme court and rigged
it up for us
have done that's impeachable now if we
had those two seats right think about it
we got two seats that leaves two seats
who would you nominate who would you
nominate to be supreme court justice now
my first instinct again is to nominate
two more black women that's my first
because there's a whole list i mean
that's one reason why joe biden said hey
we're gonna if i get a supreme court
justice nominee i'm gonna nominate a
black woman and the reason why is
because there's such a long [ __ ] list
of qualified
women who are black and who are judges
like there's a whole [ __ ] list of
them and they're all qualified the most
like the whole list is more qualified
than anyone almost anyone who's ever sat
in the nomination seat
almost any of them
that list of women black women are the
most qualified now
having said that though
that's that's a pretty good idea but
we're we're dealing in hypotheticals
here we're really dealing in fantasy so
since we're running down this
hypothetical road of who you would
um appoint supreme court justice in
those two seats
i have two nominees that i've been
saying for years
for years that i would nominate if i had
to make the decision if joe biden if
president biden is listening
i would nominate hillary rodham clinton
and barack obama
to those seats why not why not really
really [ __ ] and mug of cereal really
piss
really piss
in the queueing on cheerios that's what
i'd wanted him to do but you know again
that's hypotheticals
we don't actually have a situation where
uh clarence thomas is gonna step down or
be impeached tomorrow we do not have a
clear idea of that brett kavanaugh is
gonna pay for any crimes that may have
been committed or if he was bribed by
by paying off his debts we don't have
any of that evidence we don't have any
of
that
there's that's not reality in other
words
so what might be reality though is the
2022 midterms
think about this for a second
uh lindsey graham said it the other day
he said if republicans control the
senate a democratic president will never
be able to nominate a supreme court
justice
that's what he said
everyone's like oh sam stein you guys
remember me going after sam stein
because samsung's like oh my god
there's never going to be another
supreme court yes there's ever again
because both sides are the same shut the
[ __ ] up with that [ __ ] that's the
media's problems they both side [ __ ] and
both sides are the same [ __ ]
democrats aren't the same as republicans
just go look at the law in tennessee
where republican kid diddlers are trying
to [ __ ] marry young children
babies
go look at that law
i mean they changed it now that we
caught on to them
but go look at it it still exists it's
still there they the pedophiles didn't
go away just because they changed the
language of the bill that they want
but it's always
always this both sides things they're
not the same
so the realistic idea is that we have to
keep the senate
in the 2022 midterm you have to vote in
ohio you have to vote in missouri
you have to vote in
these senate seats are open
and they're primed for the taking
someone was mentioning here in the
comments that we have to we have to get
rid of mansion and cinema we don't have
to get rid of mansion cinema
we just have to elect more democrats to
outvote them
you got more numbers you got more votes
you don't have to rely on kamala harris
the vice president
to come in and preside over the senate
and do a a tie breaking vote you don't
have to rely on mansion and cinema to
tear down the filibuster and carve out
the filibuster for things like voting
rights or
or maybe just maybe
reform of this of this
u.s supreme court which we need four
more seats because we have four
additional districts that need to have
justices on that court
so we can add those
so
i believe that is the rub here
that's the rub
we have we have to make sure that we win
in 2022 the senate it is vitally
important because what if what if those
two seats were to come up what if that
hypothetical thing that we were just
talking about with clarence thomas and
brett kavanaugh would happen and joe
biden would get to select two supreme
court justices and let's say the
republicans and mitch mcconnell control
the senate do you think do you think
joe biden's gonna get to see those two
there's proofs in the pudding they are
not gonna let you seat supreme court
justices they've already said lindsey
graham has already said they're not
going to do it they're not going to
so go vote in florida
go vote in ohio if if you're in that
state vote vote vote vote vote
for the democrat the pro-democracy party
the party that will let joe biden seat
nominees speaking of of races here in
missouri
is speaking of
republican scumbags and kid diddlers
eric greitens is poised to win the
primary here in missouri he's the former
governor the disgraced governor who had
to resign because he duct taped
his hairdresser
to a to a treadmill in his basement make
her get naked and take dirty pictures so
he could blackmail her criminals they're
[ __ ] kid diddling
criminals
these republicans are
and i am so excited to see
um as we watch here let me put it up uh
as we go out here
i want to show you the uh
the vote here
we are going over just a bit but i do
want to show you the vote here here's
the vote for
uh katangi brown jackson let's listen in
for just a minute
aye mr young
mr young
no
mr graham mr graham
no
the boat's coming to an end here we see
there's 53 yeses
46 nos
there's only one more vote out i'm not
sure who the senator is that they're
waiting on the uh the vote for
um
it's unclear whether kamala harris will
put her
vote on the record she is presiding
um over this senate hearing you see her
there
uh up top here if you can see my mouse
she's right here sitting presiding over
the senate
uh vice president kamala harris
but this this vote here
to confirm for the u.s supreme court
makes
judge brown jackson now
when they gavel
the vote
it will be official she will be justice
katanji brown jackson
to the united states supreme court
which does not change the mix of the
court by the way as far as votes
we do not get a sway to the more liberal
side
that's all bs that they say
so it looks like we're not going to
gavel and it looks like they're waiting
on a vote
um so i'm i'm going to end it there
today thank you for joining us here on
the tony michaels podcast every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central
congratulations
to judge brown jackson now justice
katangi brown jackson in just a few
minutes it'll be official when they
gavel in this vote when kamala harris
the first black woman vice president the
first woman vice president gavels in
presiding over the senate that judge
brown jackson is now officially
it gets the nomination gets the senate
vote on confirmation
for the supreme court justice
justice katangi brown jackson we should
be a proud it's just a proud day in this
country
that we have uh the most qualified
justice
that we've seen sit in the nomination
seat
of judge brown jackson and we should be
very very proud and this country
should be honored
that she sits on the supreme court and
hopefully we will get some footage
of her being sworn in as justice brown
jackson until tomorrow remember
remember we're going to do bonehead of
the week go check out the bonehead of
the week poll
at tony michael's pod we'll post that
later today you can vote
on who you want to be bonehead of the
week and then tomorrow in the second
hour we will break down
bonehead of the week me and gabe sanchez
my co-host and executive producer here
until tomorrow noon eastern 11th century
on youtube twitter twitch live and also
coming to you from the mind facebook
page live at noon eastern 11 central
monday through friday every single one
of those days until tomorrow folks
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
commentary of current events in
political news no rules no boundaries i
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow tony on
social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking